from the moment Boris Johnson arrived in
Downing Street
one key figure was lurking in the
background Dominic Cummings has never
been far from the Prime Minister's side
as he faced brexit battles in Parliament
the eyes to the right 329 and secured a
stunning German election success
I think Dominic Cummings is undoubtedly
a genius some of his campaign successes
whether it's the brexit campaign or the
general election are extraordinary
come-from-behind victories and I think
that sort of genius inspires a lot of
loyalty from the staffers that work for
him the danger though is that it also
breeds a sort of a an arrogant Dominic
Cummings was brought up in Durham and
educated at Oxford to his allies he's
loyal supportive and talented but to his
enemies he's arrogant aggressive and
perennial elated his first taste of
political campaigning came at the turn
of the millennium when mr. Cummings led
a campaign to stop the UK adopting the
euro he was briefly director of strategy
for Ian Duncan Smith then the Tory Party
leader and Dominic Cummings later work
for Michael Gove when he was education
secretary clashing with teaching unions
and leaving under a cloud David Cameron
is said to have described him as a
career psychopath but his greatest
victory immortalized on TV by Benedict
Cumberbatch
was in 2016 when alongside Boris Johnson
mr. Cummings convinced seventeen point
four million Britons to take back
control and vote leaf now as the Prime
Minister's chief adviser his profile has
been raised yet further partly because
of his abrasive run-ins with the media
but also due to his idiosyncratic
fashion choices Prime Minister's can
only do their job if they rely on gifted
and hardworking aides in number 10 true
of the 19th century with Disraeli lad
Stern 20th century Lloyd George
Churchill Margaret Thatcher they all
need to have them the difference with
Dominic Cummings is never before in
British history has one aid being so
prominent the Downing Street Rose Garden
is usually reserved for foreign leaders
not back from a slate but this week that
changed no I don't I don't regret what I
did as I said I think reasonable people
may well disagree and the smile on his
face at the end suggested mr. Cummings
believed he got his way someone would
say oh no DOM is against that Dom
doesn't want this Dom says no to that
and that was effectively the closing
down of any discussion if it was felt
that Dominic coming somehow mind was set
against a particular course of action
there was almost no point in continuing
to argue for anything different there
was speculation when Dominic Cummings
first arrived here that he wouldn't hang
around for long but this saga has made
it abundantly clear Boris Johnson
believes mr. Cummings is just as
critical for he wants to achieve in
power as he was getting him into it the
evidence of history points very clearly
and without any equivocation to the fact
that when the aide to the Prime Minister
the
a big story themselves almost as
dominant as the Prime Minister they
cannot stay because it breaks apart
everything in our democratic
constitution for now Boris Johnson's
chief adviser is protected the comings
crisis is put to rest but with huge
challenges ahead there may well be
another on the horizon Joe Pike Sky News
Westminster